le numérique a déjà révolutionné notre
quotidien mais comment les formations
s'adapte t elle à cette évolution
c'est la question posée au campus de
l'estaca lors d'un forum des métiers du
futur
aujourd'hui les employeurs recherchent
des salariés de plus en plus compétents
le numérique
de toute façon on ne peut plus passer à
côté c'est à dire que les gens
aujourd'hui sont habitués à travailler
avec le numérique avec les médias
sociaux donc il va falloir l'intégrer
dans l'industrie du futur on aura besoin
de profils un petit peu plus polyvalent
aussi c'est des métiers qui sont
vraiment en évolution et qui sont de
plus en plus demandés dans l'entreprise
des secteurs du numérique en pleine
mutation imprimante 3d objets
intelligents réalité augmentée autant
d'opportunités qui attire de plus en
plus d'étudiants des perspectives
d'évolution font à mon sens on sont
vraiment intéressante mans on touche du
doigt une révolution quand même sur ce
point ça fait ça fait toujours plaisir
en tant qu'art manière si je peut
élargir mon champ de compétence et
l'intérêt faire du numérique ça ça
m'intéresse énormément
ce qui est important c'est de l'or ce
qui est passé de projection est ce qu'en
fait on sait dans quel secteur on va
travailler ce nouveau talent à savoir à
quoi ressemblera notre métier plus tard
à l'estac à l'école d'ingénieurs
implantée à montigny le bretonneux les
étudiants se forme aux métiers du futur
ici ils suivent un cours de technologie
automobile ou leurs compétences pourront
leur permettre d'imagés les voitures de
demain sur la voiture autonome la
technique existe et que c'est
complètement
digérer et qu'on a tout un tas de
partenariat avec des start up ou des
grands constructeurs ou des
équipementiers pour savoir où on en est
le deuxième point qui va falloir lancer
ça va être de savoir à quoi ça sert on
voit la pensée des grandes réflexions
sur qui payent qui va gagner de l'argent
avec comment à qui ça va servir en
premier comment ça va rentrer quelles
vont être les premiers véhicules les
premiers utilisateurs dans le futur les
véhicules autonomes auront un impact
fort sur l'emploi des transports au
total ce sont 3 millions d'emplois de
tous secteurs confondus qui pourraient
être détruits par la numérisation d'ici
d'où l'importance de réadapter les
formations du secteur industriel